a
[Música]
conclusión en irak
papá francisco no pudo haber sido más
positiva para el país especialmente para
la mayoría de la población que es joven
y que nunca había visto un
acontecimiento de tal magnitud al menos
no en los últimos 20 años y si estando
acostumbrados a que cada mandatario que
visita este país está rodeado de una
gran seguridad ello les hace un bloque
aunque el papá la tenía también se
acercó a la población se dejó tocar se
dejó de dar la mano y eso es muy
importante para ellos otro momento clave
tomar con la visita a nayaf al ayatolá
alí sistaní que no solamente es la
máxima figura religiosa sino también en
todos los aspectos en este país y
también reconocer a él sí mismo como un
interlocutor en ese diálogo entre
religiones acabo de marcar esta visita a
ese viaje amo azul y la cara cuyo pueblo
de mayoría cristiana donde todos
tuvieron
cuando dices dentro del 2013
i
este lunes se concluyó el viaje del papá
francisco en irak un viaje histórico que
generó preocupación en el vaticano
debido al contexto precario de seguridad
y a la situación pandémica que golpea a
este país varios momentos marcaron este
viaje la presencia del papá francisco en
la catedral de bagdad en donde cuarenta
y ocho cristianos fueron asesinados
durante un ataque terrorista en octubre
de 2010 esta fue una ocasión para el
papá francisco de manifestar un mensaje
de apoyo de esperanza a los cristianos
de irak con la comunidad que ha sido
blanco de violencia y persecución por
parte de la organización estado islámico
otro momento clave de este viaje fue el
encuentro con el gran ayatolá ali al
sistaní el líder espiritual de los
chiítas el papá subrayó la importancia
de la colaboración entre las diferentes
comunidades religiosas hizo un llamado a
la hermandad entre cristianos judíos y
musulmanes e invocó la paz para este
país martirizado por años de guerra y
violencia
[Música]
también entre la comunidad suní se ha
recibido la visita del papa- con
esperanza y como un mensaje de
fraternidad así lo ha expresado
precisamente en la máxima autoridad
religiosa de los musulmanes sunníes el
save de la mezquita de al azhar ahmed el
tayeb así señaló que esto traía un
mensaje de fraternidad esperanza y paz
al pueblo iraquí pero además deseó
suerte y deseo que el pontífice
cumpliera con sus expectativas de traer
un estrechamiento de los lazos con la
comunidad islámica de la región hace dos
años ambos líderes religiosos firmaron
un documento en el que se comprometían o
abogaban de alguna manera por la
fraternidad y la paz como como camino a
seguir entre los pueblos y hace cuatro
años también se habían reunido lo que se
consideró un primer paso para ese deseo
que el papá francisco está mostrando por
acercarse al mundo musulmán y que se ha
concretado mucho más en esta visita a
irak que en egipto por ejemplo se ha
recibido como un nuevo paso en la
dirección correcta
[Música]